got a det special airing tonight that
will ask how we can create real and
lasting change in the wake of George
Floyd's death it's called justice now a
Det news special and it will feature
interviews with activist Tameka Mallory
Senator Cory Booker and entertainer John
Legend to name just a few
and here now is an exclusive first look
at what John Legend had to say about
making progress we need to practice hope
because that's the thing that fuels us
to keep going if we don't have any hope
then we just descend into nihilism where
we're saying nothing matters if at all
burn it all down that's not the way
we're going to achieve any progress so
we have to practice hope and that means
learn from your mistakes but also get
energy from your successes and use that
to fuel you forward and have the
tenacity and the the belief that we can
keep going and make real progress that's
John Legend there be et by the way he's
part of the Viacom CBS family and one of
our family members Marc Lamont Hill he's
the host of BT news special and he joins
us now from New York good morning so I
want to talk first about what we just
heard from John Legend who he said we
need to practice hope but you know it's
also been pointed out that people have
been practicing civil disobedience and
speeching speeches and op-eds for
decades but the system has been hard to
break so what's this message of hope to
people who have seen how hard it is to
make lasting change first of all good
morning and that's a great question hope
is John Legend talks about in our
special is not the same thing as
optimism optimism is the sort of naive
belief that everything is just going to
work out fine it will just win hope is
more sober hope takes into account
struggle and one of the things that John
Legend talks about is the idea that
despite the darkness of this moment
we've made progress decade by decade by
decade by working hard by struggling and
by organizing together and so as
frustrated and as pained as this moment
is we still have an opportunity to
imagine a better future and John helps
us get there and throughout the special
all of our guests really do they help us
think about what the moment is how we
can change the moment and also where we
want to be ultimately so while we
are still living in the moment is it is
it time enough now to look ahead and
think about what the next steps are so
if the protests are kind of the sounding
of the alarm what happens in the days
and weeks and years ahead I'm it's a
great question I think whenever you
protest whenever you organize it's for
an end goal I mean when Martin King is
organizing a bus boycott when we're
sitting at the Pettis bridge there's the
short term policy goals of getting
public accommodations or getting a
Voting Rights Act passed but then
there's the long term question of what
kind of nation do we want to be in what
what is our end goal for the body
politic and that's a different question
and you have to do both at the same time
there's no sense in being on the street
organizing if you don't have something
to organize for it there's no demand to
change the system if we don't know what
kind of system we want to live in so
throughout the special tonight we talk
about both of those things again what
does it mean to be in a moment of such
pain such anger such legitimate
frustration but also what are we
fighting for not just what are we
fighting against we need to do both one
of the Gulf's that have emerged here
between police and protesters is that
protesters say look cops may not be
racist individually but the system is
producing racist results but then when
you talk to officers as I have they
don't want to use the r-word how do you
bridge that divide we have to have
honest conversation we need to draw from
our resources we need to draw from
evidence and data and we need to sort of
get people to understand what the world
likes from what the world looks like
from someone else's vantage point
because again I think they're right
there are individual cops who are great
people who you may have great
relationships great relationship with
relationships with interpersonally but
this is a systemic question this is a
structural question and I think the more
resources we pull into the conversation
the more we can get people to understand
just last week look at how many people
who didn't understand police violence
can suddenly understand it differently
when they see George Floyd in that awful
video but that's something that I think
everyone can understand is problematic
I'm not saying we need more video but we
do need more conversation about such
videos so that we can get to a place
where everyone recognizes implicit bias
everyone understands structural racism
and everyone understands their
complicity in that system so when you
add it all up what do you hope people
take away from this moment and also from
the special tonight
I hope people see this as a moment of
crisis but also a moment of opportunity
and what we do tonight is show that you
know Cory Booker gives us a way out
helps us think of a way out along with
Tameka Mallory in terms of voting
Nicole Hannah Jones the purely surprise
winning journalist helps us think about
the history of pain and trauma and how
we can heal from that and talk to our
family members about that our children
especially in each segment of the
special we talk about what the moment is
how trying this moment is but also we
offer a way out or at least some
possibilities for a way out that can
bring us together but to do someone to
mature in honest fashion all right Marc
Lamont Hill thank you very much I look
forward to the special tonight you can
watch it it's called justice now a BT
news special it's on tonight on be et at
8:00 p.m. 7:00 central